if you've been looking for a sign that
we may be nearing an end to the National
fever dream that began sometime in the
past decade and that soon will once
again live in a country where you can at
least talk about basic facts of life
without losing your job or getting
dogpiled on social media then what
happened last week wasn't just
encouraging it was proof that we're well
on our way to that destination that may
be hard to believe but it's true and
there's no denying it now last week for
the first time in a very long time it
wasn't the people who understand human
biology and the differences between men
and women who lost their jobs it wasn't
the people who value freedom of speech
who are publicly humiliated it wasn't
the civilized and respectful people who
had to lock down their accounts and
shame instead for once the Thugs who
can't win an argument without threats
and coercion were the ones backed into a
corner for a change the premiere of what
is a woman on Twitter proved to be a
disastrous moment for these very Petty
and aggressively stupid authoritarians
as we've told you after the daily wire
signed a deal with Twitter to stream the
film for free to kick off pride month
a faction of dedicated sensors within
Twitter many of them holdovers from the
pre-musk era we can assume decided to
revolt it went back on the agreement
they told us the film was hate speech
because for the very simple reason that
it contains speech they hated and
whatever it took these activists inside
Twitter decided the last possible minute
that um you wouldn't be allowed to see
any of it and you know that whole story
by now now I say activists but these
people are more like zealots the
ideology is what matters to them nothing
else and that's why several of these
Rogue Twitter employees decided to throw
away their jobs in order to shut down
what is a woman that's how dedicated
they are to the cult of gender ideology
even after Elon Musk publicly told the
daily wire CEO Jeremy boring that the
film would run without any censorship
these activists went ahead and throttled
it anyway the moment it went live on
Twitter on the night of June 1st and as
you know no one could like or retweet it
had a label saying it contained hateful
conduct it looked for a while as if
somehow this Pro censorship faction
within Twitter had staged some kind of
coup they had defied Twitter's owner and
Incredibly at first it seemed they had
gotten what they wanted
but then Elon Musk stepped in heads
rolled various firings and resignations
were reported and the film was three
freed from the censorship shackles
but once the rest of America the sane
ones anyway had the opportunity to see
the film without any intervention from a
small number of gender studies majors in
Silicon Valley
it became obvious why the sensors were
so desperate to shut us down to begin
with
they were right in a certain way not
right to do what they did
not write about the things they believe
but right to be afraid of the film and
the effect it would have on their agenda
because what happened next was truly
historic it turns out a lot of people
wanted to watch the film in fact more
people wanted to watch what is a woman
than any other documentary in the last
several years
when we tweeted out the film it got more
than 170 million views now for
perspective
more people watched what is a woman than
saw Anderson Cooper all week on CNN or
watched the Oscars or Joe Biden's State
of the Union Address in 2023 combined
the film trended worldwide all weekend
with hundreds of thousands of people
talking about it all at all hours
for the second pride month in a row this
is our second one in a row what is a
woman was the number one documentary on
Rotten Tomatoes and in fact right now is
the number one streaming film on the
entire site so just to restate this is a
documentary that came out a year ago and
it instantly went to number one again
whatever you think of the film based on
the data there's no question it's one of
the most watched documentaries of the
past decade it's also one of the most
impactful because it's led directly to
laws that have been passed all over the
country outlawing child mutilation other
crimes against humanity in fact it's
clear that that now we can say what is a
woman is one of the most widely viewed
and influential documentaries not just
of the past several years or of the
decade but of all time and I'm biased in
that assessment of course but all of the
available metrics back it up
what an unmitigated disaster for the
forces of censorship and of evil
the news organizations and big Tech
oligarchs who for years
could have censored this film uh you
know and would have censored it in this
case as well we're instead forced to
watch on the sidelines as all this
unfolded watching helplessly
millions of Americans could see the
extent to which they're being lied to
the experts in medicine and Academia
that the media throws in our faces who
tell us that gender ideology has settled
science
actually have no idea what they're
talking about they're clowns and liars
and frauds small children could make
better arguments than they do
and they've all been exposed as liars
and not about some trivial topic either
they've been covering for an ideology
that condones the forcible castration
and mutilation of children and there's
no hiding that now
but of course they're going to try to
hide it anyway despite its popularity
right now the film still has not been
reviewed by a single corporate media
Outlet instead they spent the weekend
and the past week lying about it here's
how CNN
covered everything that's happened uh
listen to this
meantime Twitter's head of trust and
safety telling Reuters that she has
resigned from the social media company
Ella Irwin who was in charge of content
moderation stepped down the same day
that Twitter blocked and then unblocked
access to an anti-trans documentary
billionaire Elon Musk has faced
criticism for lacks protections against
potentially harmful content since he
took over back in October
now notice a couple things about that
club the first is that like Voldemort
you can't actually say the name of the
movie I think that's correct I don't
usually use Harry Potter references but
anyway so instead of what is a woman
it's an anti-trans documentary that
shall not be named under any
circumstance merely saying the words
what is a woman is violence and what's
amusing about calling the film an
anti-trans documentary is that again the
whole documentary is about giving trans
activists the floor letting them speak
we didn't interrupt them or edit
anything out of context so if what is a
woman is an anti-trans documentary a CNN
says all that means is that gender
ideology is so incoherent and so corrupt
that anyone who spends any time
listening to pro-trans activists will
inevitably Come Away with anti-trans
sentiments that seems to be what CNN is
saying
Now CNN doesn't realize they're saying
that of course because none of them have
watched the film or know what they're
talking about
but that's the big takeaway from that
segment spend 10 minutes with a doctor
who performs gender affirming surgeries
quote unquote gender affirming surgeries
or or a college professor who lectures
on gender and you'll come away
anti-trans apparently
that's what CNN is saying and that might
not be a bad assessment from CNN
actually the other thing to notice about
that clip is the implication that the
film contains potentially harmful
content nowhere in that segment that CNN
explain what's potentially harmful about
letting trans activists box themselves
into a corner and then run away
screaming when asked a simple question
maybe what CNN means is that the content
of the film is harmful
to gender ideology which it certainly is
if that's the case then again we thank
CNN for the endorsement
now to be clear I'm not just picking on
CNN here that would be a waste of time
because as Elon Musk pointed out in
response to that segment nobody watches
them anyway so you should know that the
rest of the media did the same thing
they attacked the film without even
mentioning the title of it or what it's
about NBC news for example ran this
headline quote musk's response to an
anti-trans video Sparks 24 hours of
chaos at Twitter a conservative pressure
movement built against Twitter CEO
resulted in high level departures from
the company
now you couldn't write a less factually
accurate summary of what happened over
the past week if you tried
they can't even bring themselves to call
it a film instead one of the most widely
viewed documentaries ever is just a
video an anti-trans video
uh what's remarkable about this is that
millions of people are seeing the fake
narrative machines spin up in real time
what happened on Twitter with what is
woman is not a secret everyone could see
it happen
and yet the media is lying about it as
if this is russiagate all over again
they're acting like they have some kind
of Insider knowledge and they can fool
people but they can't
again they're panicking and more
importantly it's obvious
this is how these people start to lose
power because they lose their grip their
influence
the Monopoly they have over people's
minds
the closest the NBC news article comes
to engaging with the content of the film
is to say that it misgenders trans
people quoting from NBC it says quote
misgendering trans people had been
restricted on the platform since 2018
but under musk the company quietly
repealed that rule misgendering trans
people using pronouns other than what
someone prefers is a common way to bully
trans people
what NBC doesn't mention is that the
alleged misgendering they're talking
about again is a father saying that his
14 year old girl is his daughter they're
saying that his this father was bullying
his own 14 year old daughter
bullying her because he objected when
doctors injected her with cross-sex
hormones that sterilized her
and then when the Canadian government
arrested this father and fined him
thirty thousand dollars and when the
Canadian media destroyed his life
according to NBC he wasn't being bullied
instead his daughter was being bullied
that's what they're saying now they
can't write that explicitly because it's
just so awful and insane so they lie
about it in the not too distant past
private citizens used to be largely that
private well change well the internet
changed think about everything you've
ever searched for watched or tweeted on
the internet now imagine all that data
being crawled through collected and
aggregated by Third parties into
permanent public records to keep my data
private when I go online I use
expressvpn there are hundreds of data
Brokers out there whose sold business
involves buying and selling your data
they don't even have to tell you who
they're selling it to or get your
consent one of the one of these data
points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your physical location
but you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted server
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me sounds complicated
but really you just have to open the app
and tap one button on whatever device
you're using IF like me you believe that
your data is your business secure
yourself with the number one rated VPN
on the market use MyLink expressvpn.com
Matt walshow to get three extra months
free that's
expressvpn.com
expresvpn.com Matt Walsh show now the
one redeeming quality of the mvcr
article is that it contains this line
which belongs in some kind of Museum or
something quote musk's views on trans
rights put him out of sync with many
other Silicon Valley billionaires
okay this is how Shameless corporate
media propaganda is now they come right
out and condemn you if you disagree with
many other Silicon Valley billionaires
as if that's obviously a bad thing to do
now I'm old enough to remember when the
left used to pretend to be critics of
the evil billionaire class
now they use that group as a moral
measuring stick for the rest of us it
used to be billionaires are evil now
it's agree with all the billionaires or
your evil
everywhere you look this weekend there
was an article like this clearly written
by someone who hadn't seen the film but
was told to write about it
take Business Insider for example unlike
NBC or CNN Business Insider actually did
use the name of the film so at least
there's that but they obviously haven't
seen it either they wrote that the film
quote urges intolerance of trans people
of course they don't provide a single
quote in which anyone in the documentary
urges intolerance of trans people
that's because it didn't happen
and now everyone knows that because
everyone can see it for themselves
the new Republic ran a similarly
embarrassing piece except to try and
differentiate themselves a bit they
opted to attack Elon Musk personally
they reported that he was quote disowned
by his trans daughter and the article
went on to lament that musk had decided
to quote punch down against transgender
people
is anyone convinced by this anymore
it's hard to believe at this point
the activists who are urging intolerance
are on the other side they're doing it
right out in the open
they aren't dog whistling or whatever
they're coming out and saying it
and for them when they call for
intolerance against their enemies they
don't mean just like say mean things
about them they mean kill them
for the latest example as journalist
Chris Brunet reported on his sub stack
this weekend a Brown University PHD
student calling himself Sarah Celeste
Griffith has for apparently many months
been publicly urging people to come to
my home and kill me
um why well presumably because Sarah
Celeste Griffith is a man who claims to
be a woman and he is so desperate to
maintain this delusion that he wants
anyone who tells the truth to be killed
now I've been saying this for a long
time because it's true
trans activists would happily murder you
and your whole family for the sake of
feeling more Affirmed
or at a minimum they'll happily
encourage someone else to go do it
Brown University is aware that this
person has been threatening me
um but they haven't done anything about
it
as we expect and by the way uh if you'd
like to reach out to the president
University to ask why they're allowing
this kind of behavior why one of their
PhD students is publicly calling for the
execution of someone they disagree with
on social media and you want to know why
they would allow this at Brand
University well you can contact the
president of the University Christina
Paxson at
401-863-2234 or you can email president
brown.edu if you want to give your
feedback then that's the way that you do
it I'm sure that she I mean as always
you know I'm sure she'd be very happy to
hear it
uh now when you when you when you
contact you might want to ask her why
they're protecting Sarah Celeste
Griffith and ignoring these terroristic
threats though I mean we already know
the answer
they're doing it for the same reason Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris ignore every
instance of trans-terrorism including
the murder of children
they're ignoring us for the same reason
there are Pride flags all over
Rockefeller Center right now the reason
they think they can ignore it ignore us
is that criticizing The Cult of gender
ideology is not in fact punching down
and they know that
it is standing up to the most powerful
forces in our country
which insists that you lie about the
most fundamental Facts of Life
they want you to believe men can get
pregnant and if you disagree
they try to crush you
they think they have all the power
but they don't have all of it I mean
they have a lot of it
but they don't have all of it not
anymore
so they have to resort to propaganda
that's getting increasingly desperate
here's another example The Huffington
Post cut right to the chase in their
article about what is a woman and the
the Twitter controversy and their
headline was Elon Musk is a transphobe
what's their evidence for that here it
is quote gender affirming Health Care
takes place in a professional
environment
that's what they say and therefore
according to the Huffington Post don't
you dare ask questions about hospitals
that castrate children it's happening in
a nice and professional environment and
if you do ask questions about it you're
afraid of trans people
the reality is that these media outlets
for once are the ones who are afraid
they're flailing around trying to attack
a film they clearly haven't seen and
certainly don't want you to see
and they're doing that because they know
they're losing ground
the revolt against trans ideology is
gaining steam more and more each day
Texas just became the largest state to
criminalize uh child mutilation or
gender affirming care as the media puts
it that happened uh just last week
18 other states have signed similar
legislation many of them in just the
past year
meanwhile corporations are starting to
run scared from pride month
there are a bunch that didn't even
switch their Twitter logos over to the
little rainbow colors this year like
they have in years past as news news we
just reported quote The North Face Lego
in Miller Lite carried supportive
messages on June 1st 2022 but did not do
so this year other brands such as Target
Bud Light and Adidas have yet to post
despite doing so later in June last year
the account for Xbox briefly had a pride
logo that they put up on their Twitter
account before getting rid of it a few
days into pride month the Navy did the
same thing they made their background
image on Twitter and Instagram a fighter
jet streaking across the sky with pride
colors in its wake then they got
dogpiled because the job of the military
is to defend us from foreign enemies not
to promote fetishes and the sexual
mutilation of children and the people
you know people are comfortable saying
that out loud now
so very quickly the Navy changed their
background image back now
these might seem like small victories
but there are manifestations of a larger
and more significant trend
the media knows this the left knows this
which is why they're panicking
a lot of people thought that the left
had won the cultural argument when it
comes to trans and LGBT stuff that was
the Assumption many people made that
this is lost they won there's no one
doing it
but the victory was an illusion like a
mirage in the desert when you get closer
and you get a closer look you see it for
the fraud that it is
they win quote unquote by preventing
people from looking at these issues
honestly or thinking about them clearly
or talking about them at all
this is also one of the reasons why Libs
of tick tock became one of their most
hated enemies
she just gave people an honest look at
their agenda which is what they fear
most
once people start to see this for what
it is
and they feel empowered to talk about it
things start to change rapidly
and right now they are
thanks for checking out this video if
you liked listen to my full podcast on
the go you can check out the Matt Walsh
show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast